but the doj may have other things that
they have in mind as well because
according to reports out this week the
doj is also seeking more
surveillance footage from Mar-A-Lago
now as we all know the doj already has
their hands on some of the surveillance
footage from Mar-A-Lago and in fact it
was getting that surveillance footage
that kind of expedited the need for the
FBI to go down there and seize all these
documents to begin with and now Reports
say the doj needs even more they want
more
and that can only mean one thing
according to the experts
that one thing of course
is that they didn't get it all that
there could be more documents hiding
down there in Mar-A-Lago or maybe
maybe they were loaded up and taken
somewhere else
so that when the FBI showed up some of
the even worse stuff that Trump may have
stolen
wasn't even on site and they didn't know
that he had moved it that's why they
want that surveillance footage at least
that's the prevailing Theory
honestly makes a heck of a lot of sense
these doj investigators are not doing
this willy-nilly right they're not
flying by the seat of their pants
they're making sure that they have
crossed their T's that they have dotted
their eyes and that they have the
evidence to back up any claim or request
that they make because they understand
the political ramifications of going
after a former president especially one
with a cult following like Donald Trump
especially one whose followers are out
there right now making death threats
against the very people doing these
investigations
and they're looking at all that and
they're looking at their evidence and
they're saying you know what
we need more
so for them to even think that right now
tells me they have what they believe I
think is pretty strong evidence that
they don't have all of the evidence
and that's a terrifying thought in and
of itself right Trump could be hiding
even more documents there could there
could be more than just the 700 pages of
classified information some of it again
pertaining to nuclear documents
I I'd say that's a worth a look through
the footage right I think that's
something maybe we want to be looking
into
it remains to be seen of course they
have not officially
made the request for that extra
surveillance footage it could be coming
any day now
we have to wait and see and that that
honestly is is always the hardest part
right especially with Donald Trump
we have to be patient just like we have
to be patient with the January 6
hearings we have to be patient with the
New York investigations and then the
Georgia investigation and the lawsuits
about him possibly inciting the riot
causing the injuries to the police
officers and the E Gene Carroll
defamation lawsuit which honestly still
to me in my opinion is the biggest one
out there
um because of what it could prove about
Donald Trump if he ever gives that DNA
sample so there's a lot of things
which means we got to have a lot of
patience
always easy but that's the position that
we are in right now
I am Farren cousins for more from me by
the way you can follow me on YouTube at
youtube.com the ring of fire you can
also follow my other YouTube channel at
youtube.com
fahrenbalanced and I'm on Twitter
Facebook and Instagram at
farrenbalanced this is the David packman
show I'm Farren cousins in for David
packman and we'll be right back with
more
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and Bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa Honey Nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
Maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
I love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but I know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com Pacman the link is down
below